good news the war in ukraine is over
folks
zielinski has not repelled the russians
putin has not stopped the invasion
nothing like that has happened but
nancy pelosi has figured out how to end
the war
she does not have a peace plan to broker
and she has not managed to get those
polish fighter jets to the ukrainians or
or anything like that but
but she does have a poem written by bono
what you saw yesterday was history later
at the lunch just maybe you might want
to watch i'm going to be reading a poem
written by bono about ukraine which you
might find interesting
what's that president zelinski you you
want a global military effort to save
your country
yeah the best i'm going to be able to do
is a poem from bono and maybe you want
to watch i don't maybe just tune in i
don't know i think i read it pretty well
um
they say as we get older we become more
ourselves apparently this is the case
with nancy pelosi
this is like pelosi concentrate this is
the most
caricaturish
pelosi
experience i could possibly imagine
here's my answer to this global
potentially nuclear conflict i'm going
to read a poem
by bono and the poem did not disappoint
i got this message this morning from
bono
and most of us we're always whether
we're in ireland or here or whatever it
is avano has been a very irish part of
our lives
and he said
this he said
oh saint patrick
he drove out the snakes with his prayers
but that's normally that's not all it
takes
but the smoke symbolizes an evil that
arises and hides in your heart as it
breaks and the evil from risen from
friends from the darkness that lives in
some men but in sorrow and fear that's
when saints can appear
to drive out those old snakes once again
and they struggle for us to be free from
the psycho in this human family
ireland sorrow and pain is now the
ukraine
and saint patrick's name is now zawinski
oh
okay on with our lunch that does it
right the war is over
take that putin
now of course ireland is not ukraine
they're very different countries
and zelensky is not a fifth century
roman christian missionary or a saint of
any kind that would require him to have
died and he isn't any of those things
anyway and bono's babbling and nancy
pelosi's babbling didn't do anything
other than make democrats feel better
about their disastrous policies that
triggered this war in the first place
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
there once was a man named joe biden
who when he first started president
gave into vlad's order for nordstream
the border of ukraine is quickly
subsident
joe biden's strategic perversion
incentivized putin's excursion he
invited invasion of a sovereign nation
but only a minor incursion folks i could
be here all day and i promise you every
one of my poems will be better than
bono's and will more importantly be more
accurate than bonos this was such it it
was a revolting display to see the
democrats
pretending that they're in any way
helping it's like that little meme of on
the simpsons i'm helping i'm i'm helping
by reading a poem by bono uh no you're
not you're not doing you caused the
freaking war in the first place because
your political party lifted the
sanctions off putin's nordstrom two
pipeline this is what vladimir zielinski
the man you're calling a saint now he
actually said this is why the war
started and now you're making yourself
feel better by reading some
babbling nonsense my favorite comment
yesterday is from the drummer's workshop
at norm's music
to celebrate jesse smallett's luck on
this st patrick's day i declare him to
be a leprechaun vict
that's true you know leprechauns are
certainly more realistic than the two
men that jesse smilet hired to play
white supremacists to attack him this is
moga country get out of here empire
josie we're coming to get you on behalf
of trump it's uh it's a very sick story
it's a very dirty story when you want to
clean up not just your society but your
home i would strongly recommend you
check out naturally it's clean right now
go to naturallyitsclean.com michael when
you are picking a cleaning product i
know i've had this thought before i
always think it's a big debate between
do you want something that's super
effective that's going to clean up the
mess or do you want something that's not
going to kill your kids or pets right do
you get the thing that's full of all the
harsh chemicals
but it's going to be it's going to work
really well or do you get the thing
that's made out of like bubble gums and
unicorn tears but it's not going to
actually clean
you don't need to
make that decision anymore you can get
the best of both worlds with naturally
it's clean a hospital-grade cleaning
product that will not leave harmful
chemicals on all of your surfaces
naturally it's clean is a home cleaning
company dedicated to providing the most
effective cleaning products for your
home while reducing the use of harmful
chemicals what's the secret the powerful
plant-based enzymes nature's solution to
cleaning when i'm talking powerful i
mean i mean
real real
hospital level enzyme cleaning power
naturally it's clean has safer chemistry
that just works right now you get 15 off
when you head on over to
naturalflightsclean.com go get the daily
wire essentials kit stocked with four
great products it's naturalizedclean.com
michael
use promo code michael uh that is uh
incredible cleaning products the best
you're ever gonna use 15 off go to
natural it's clean dot com slash michael
promo code michael
go check out naturally it's clean today
i i can't get over the poem because it's
not it's not just pelosi
it's not just bono it's not just the
house democrats it's not even just joe
biden it's the whole
liberal establishment
they
they don't know anything
they are
extremely emotional
and and confident in the things that
they don't know anything about they're
extremely vindictive if you raise any
questions about whatever crusade they've
taken on that day that they're just
going to change tomorrow i love it if
you go to your liberal friends facebook
profiles try this experiment i did it
yesterday go to a random liberal friends
facebook profile
and i just go back
through the pictures and you'll notice
very often it's the same profile picture
and it'll just be different images
superimposed on top
to d now today it's it's ukraine which
is probably the worthiest cause they've
had ever in the last 20 years but then
you go before ukraine what is it
it's the french flag superimposed over
the same picture why why because i
thought what was the cause oh right
because of the charlie hebdo shooting
okay then it's the french flag then
before that or maybe after i kind of
forget which order then it's the gay
flag why was it the gay flaw what oh
because of the orlando it was the
orlando shooting remember when the
muslim guy shot up the gay nightclub
okay before and before that it was what
then you go back and it's kony 2012. you
remember kony 2012 that was one of the
first social media meme
slacktivism campaigns where you change
your profile picture and you feel like
you're doing something did we ever get
kony by the way i don't i don't think we
ever got kony i don't think anything
ever happened
no one knew who kony was no one knows
anything about any of these crusades
they just get really ginned up you you
have a kind of mass hysteria
you you feel all of this emotion
but
you you don't know anything about what's
causing it other than just propaganda
from the mainstream media and you don't
even more importantly you don't do
anything to help or change anything it's
all personal the clearest example of
this i've seen in
years actually was a post from the
american federation of teachers
this is the national teachers union and
it was these two union bosses
holding up a sign yellow and and blue so
in the flag of ukraine and it said we
stand with ukraine
printed on it so this was designed
somewhere and they printed out a bunch
of these signs
and the
most ridiculous part of the image
is that the flag is upside down
they did this
the flag is upside down the flag printed
by
the teachers union
is there any greater summation of the
american educational system today
than
two union thugs holding up a foreign
flag
upside down
as though they are the great moral
leaders
they have no idea what they're doing
they can't teach their students anything
they don't they don't know what they are
talking about
they're gung-ho to jump on whatever the
crusade is of the day
and they're confidently smiling tweeting
this out they couldn't even google it
hey what's the ukraine flag look like
holding it upside down it was very funny
then too later you saw a picture of a
bunch of other of these teacher union
people holding up the flags but then
some of the it was a mixture some were
the yellow on top of the blue some were
the blue on top of the yellow and then
when you looked closely at the ones that
that were accurate with the blue on top
of the yellow you noticed
they photoshopped it
because they were all printed wrong
because these teacher union people don't
know a damn thing about anything
and then they did a crappy job
photoshopping it since then they have
taken down the posts but that's it
that's our american educational system
and
what you see in classrooms what you see
on campuses is a crystal ball so what
you see there is what your country is
going to look like 20 years from now
this degradation of our education system
has been going on for decades already
and so now we're seeing the fruits of
that in our government which is why our
government seems completely feckless in
the light of this geopolitical crisis
and pretty much all the other ones too
because there's really no difference
between the completely ignorant
educators
that are teaching these generations of
students and now the completely ignorant
political leaders who were taught by
them
it's it's as though these people are not
really teachers well actually the
teacher union thugs are not teachers
they're union bosses right they they
just play teachers on tv
and their main job is to keep schools
closed that's what they've been doing
for the past two years even after the
science showed that covid wasn't a big
deal for kids
pretty much ever that the risk to kids
was lower than the risk to basically
anybody else from kovid even after that
the union thug said no you're not going
back to school
now we're going to keep it close because
they don't advocate for students they
don't advocate for education they
advocate to get more vacation time for
their union members
they're not teachers they just play them
on tv that's how i feel about our
statesman
or when you think of great statesmen
throughout history winston churchill
it's a matter nick i know you think of
all these statesmen throughout history
then you get to joe biden
joe biden doesn't know any kamala harris
knows even less than joe biden does at
least joe biden's old so he can't he was
never the brightest bulb in the pack
he's always had wind blowing through his
ears but he came of political age at a
time when you did kind of have to know a
little bit about government and politics
if you wanted to be in the government
kamala harris did not we are we are now
living in virtual reality government
right we are now living in a time where
you don't really need to know much of
anything to be in the government it's
it's as though they're not statesmen
they just play statesmen
on tv and so it is no surprise probably
the the greatest example of this
is stacy abrams the pretend governor of
georgia stacey abrams ran for governor
of georgia she lost to brian kemp
and then
she just didn't concede she just
pretended she was governor of georgia
and even though she couldn't live in the
governor's mansion she would go around
and started non-profits to raise money
get her face out there
she goes on tv as though she's an
elected politician she's not she holds
no office
and if you were tuning into star trek
recently you would turn on and find out
that stacey abrams is not just a failed
gubernatorial candidate in georgia she's
actually president of
the universe
that's a very terrifying in that kind of
world you probably can't rely on public
services you're gonna have to do for
yourself which is why you gotta go check
out rockauto.com
now go to rockauto.com and write knowles
in their how did you hear about us box
whatever part you need for your car or
truck you've got two options you can go
to the brick and mortar auto parts store
and you can take 20 minutes to drive
there and then you go and you wait in
line for five minutes then the guy
peppers you with questions for two
minutes and he goes in the back it takes
three four minutes and he comes back he
doesn't have it and he goes the order is
online and then you gotta wait because
they never have the product stuck okay
that's one world right and you go back a
couple weeks later you get okay or or
you go to rockauto.com you can do it
from your phone from your computer the
website is so easy to navigate even i
can do it no gimmicks
no you have to log in at this time with
this thing and then you get the 10 off
no it's just always reliably low prices
same prices for pros as
do-it-yourselfers
comes right to your door very reliable
family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years what are
you going to pick it's obvious to me go
to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck then
write knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
go check out rock auto
today
stacey abrams she lost the governorship
of georgia she gained
the presidency the chancellorship of the
entire universe according to an episode
of star trek
we greet the president of united earth
[Music]
madam president
president welcome i am so pleased that
you've come we are eager to begin
diplomatic discussions
nothing to discuss
united earth is ready right now to
rejoin the federation
and nothing could make me happier than
to say those words
thank you thank you all okay i've got to
fact check myself i don't watch star
trek and i certainly don't watch stacey
abrams so she's the president of earth
not not they were they would never be so
ambitious as to say she's president of
the universe not yet she's the president
of earth and she's united the whole
earth and now they're going to join i
guess the galactic federation with darth
vader and i don't know i don't watch any
of these shows
the first thing i noticed about this
clip from stacey abrams if you're only
listening you wouldn't have noticed this
right now
they only ever have the camera on stacey
abrams for about two to three seconds at
a time
presumably this is because her
performance was terrible and so they had
to just construct her performance so
even if she's speaking it'll cut to a
clip of someone else will come to a clip
behind her because she's she's not an
actress she's a politician and a failed
politician at that but the libs are so
desperate to get her into office that
they are going to use everything at
their disposal not just the legacy media
the news media to
lie about her and lie about that
election and give her the biggest boost
she can get in her
race to try to get the governorship
again but they're going to use hollywood
they're going to use everything
available to them to meme her into
office let me ask you something
why should stacey abrams be the governor
of georgia even if you're i doubt there
are very many stacey abrams supporters
listening to this show maybe there are
some though we have liberal listeners we
have democrat listeners
wha what is it about stacey abrams
that
makes her qualified to be the governor
of georgia
what has she done
what what does she do that means she
should be the governor of georgia
if stacey abrams's
supporters are being honest with
themselves
they will admit
nothing
nothing no accomplishment no particular
quality about her means she should be
governor other than her sex and her race
that is what that's why people like her
or that's why people pretend to like her
because she just plays identity politics
this is the only reason kamala harris is
the vice president
don't take my word for it that's what
joe biden said he said i'm only going to
pick a black woman
meaning i think it's electorally
beneficial to me to
purely play identity politics pick a
black woman so i'm just going to pick a
black woman and he only had three
options available to him really it was
uh carol karen bass who's that communist
congresswoman like an actual literal
communist congresswoman she wasn't going
to work
kamala harris who was extremely
unlikable first out in the democrat
primary she didn't seem like she could
work or susan rice who was obama's fall
guy for benghazi so of three bad options
he picked kamala harris she's the least
popular vice president in
recent history she's less popular than
dick cheney was after he shot a man in
the face after the iraq war after
everything that made him unpopular she's
very unpopular so why did he pick her he
said he only picked her because of the
color of her skin and her sex
why is katanji jackson the supreme court
nominee the only reason is because of
the color of her skin and her sex don't
take my word for it that's what joe
biden said
why is stacey abrams a thing only
because of the color of her skin and her
sex that's that's what the supporters
are talking about
now i'm not downplaying her political
skills she's done a pretty good job of
remaining in the news even after she
just keeps losing even she should have
gone away after that election and she
has she's so she's she's a clever and
shrewd politician in that way
but the only reason that people are
supporting her is because of these
superficial
virtual things oh she should be the
governor of georgia because she's the
president of the earth that's why
they're going to try to meme her into
office
and and
this is a big problem
when you're living in a virtual world
then when real life problems come at you
you're not going to be prepared for them
when we're living in a world
of virtual problems
transgenderism
intersect white supremacy
systemic racism problems that are
completely fictional that only exist in
people's imaginations
then when vladimir putin rolls tanks
into ukraine people have no idea what
the hell to do
because that
that seems so old-timey well hold on
people still roll tanks into foreign
countries hold on there are still
invasions there's still war i thought we
were past all that i thought that our
biggest problem now was making sure that
hulking dudes can swim in the ivy league
women's swim championship
wait you're telling me we still have to
deal with real problems like territory
and geography and weapons and buffer
states and strategic interests and
alliances huh i don't know anything
about that but let me read you a poem by
bono i'm really good at that and that's
all they can do and that's why we seem
impotent and feckless on the world stage
the propaganda is getting the better of
us i'm not opposed to to polities to
states using propaganda especially in
times of war but just in general that's
what all states have done throughout
history but what's so crazy in this
world that we're in now where we're
constantly consuming information
where we're scrolling all day long
is that we are the victims of our own
propaganda it's not like in the cold war
when the us would beam propaganda into
the soviet union and other states
we're beaming propaganda to ourselves
and so then we believe our own
propaganda
we're violating the most important rule
my mother ever taught me i was i was a
kid i was getting a head that was a
little too big
because i don't know i was doing well in
school or something like that and she
said hey michael
don't believe your own press releases
right don't believe your own propaganda
that's what we've fallen into
and it has really really damaged us
here's a great example of propaganda
this is my favorite headline
in recent weeks it's from axios came out
on march 12th
the rise of white nationalist hispanics
and they're talking about that guy nick
fuentes is the he's the picture but
they're talking about a lot of other
people uh enrique tario who is the head
of the proud boys right that was and uh
the proud voice is a white supremacist
organization well how come the head of
it is a black cuban guy that's kind of
weird isn't it
there a few other people too
the white nationalist hispanic first
thing i noticed about this article
i thought we weren't supposed to use the
word hispanic anymore
i thought hispanic was an old word it's
wrong it's imprecise
just refers to the spanish language but
not to race or ethnicity i thought i
thought we're supposed to say la tinx
remember le tinx they're trying to make
latinx happen at least we should say
latino right so why hispanic
it's describing the same people as le
tinx but they say why oh because le tinx
is for the good ones and hispanic is for
the bad ones
la tinx which is a word used by what two
percent of
mexicans guatemalans you know all the
people who count as hispanic or latino
or whatever it's used by two percent of
those people
but latinx is for the good woke ones
hispanic that's for the old
conservative right-wing
bad ones
okay so they're white nationalist
hispanics what does that mean
it means they're very confused i guess
the implication is that there are these
people
who
are not white
but they want whites to rule the world
and gosh aren't they so stupid
well the i guess the implication is that
the
the hispanics they'll become part of the
whites
they'll they'll be they'll meld into the
same thing and that's really bad well
hold on why is that really bad isn't
that isn't that what we're all kind of
after don't we want race not to matter
that much and we all with something a
little deeper animates us than just race
isn't that a good thing if if the
hispanics and the whites which were
separate groups and there were all these
power dynamics and oppression and
intersectionality if they can become the
same thing isn't that good isn't that
what you want
works for me
oh no well it's bad for some reason okay
then there's a second question that
comes from this which is
axios and the left is looking at this
issue of the white nationalist system
was a black cuban guy running the proud
boys i was told it was a white
supremacist group they could never come
to the conclusion that it's actually not
a white supremacist group which is the
real conclusion but forget that for a
second
axios is asking
why would a hispanic guy
behave in the way that i'm calling white
supremacist
or white nationalist or whatever the
term is
the better question is
why do the white nationalists
accept these hispanic guys
in the case of enrique torrio
a black hispanic guy
why do the white supremacists accept
these guys as their leaders
the obvious answer is
because they're not white supremacists
because they're not anti-hispanic
because they're not anti-black
because there's something else going on
okay now i'm
i don't know anything about enrique
tario i don't really know anything about
nick fuentes i met him one time and he
was a jerk to me so i don't you know i
don't i don't i'm not saying anything
about these groups i'm talking about
the issue itself i'm talking about the
headline
maybe race is not
playing the role
in forget the groups in our whole
politics
that the left
says that it is playing just maybe i
don't know i'm throwing that up maybe
that maybe the left has believed its own
propaganda a little too long and now
they're having trouble grappling with
reality
the propaganda issue is not just
what is said
but also what we are not allowed to say
we pride ourselves we've got a a free
open
country don't we
we've got this free wonderful open
system well
uh if if we do have this free open press
uh how come they keep censoring stuff
you remember you remember during the
2020 election
you had
the hunter biden laptop story the new
york post broke this story there was
this hunter biden laptop that was
discovered it had a ton of compromising
material not just a bunch of stuff with
drugs and hookers and potential
personal lurid crimes like that
but a bunch of stuff about hunter
biden's dealings in china a bunch of
stuff about hunter biden's shady
dealings in ukraine
a bunch of stuff that implicated
joe biden
in hunter's shady business dealings in
china and ukraine
and when you tried to post that article
on social media
you weren't allowed to twitter facebook
google all these places shut it down
when you tried to privately message your
friends with this article
you weren't allowed to why because the
official story coming out of our press
was this is dangerous
false
hacked
russian
disinformation
judge a bunch of questions from this let
me just start with this
how much does the source matter right so
you hear the story of this laptop we
don't know a lot we do know that the the
way that this information is getting out
is through steve bannon and rudy
giuliani how much do the does the source
matter here
well source matters a lot and uh and the
timing matters a lot i think and to me
this is uh this classic
uh textbook uh soviet russian
tradecraft at work
the russians have analyzed the target
they understand that the president and
his enablers crave
dirt on vice president biden whether
it's real or contrived that doesn't
matter to them
and so all of a sudden two two and a
half weeks before the election
this
laptop appears somehow
without any emails on it without any
metadata
uh it's just it's all very curious do
you think stuff like that could just
have been planted in there and be
completely fake
i do
i think the uh the emails could be
could be contrived
it's totally completely fake that's not
just some random talking head on cnn who
is giving that opinion well the the
anchor was she is just a random leftist
propagandist on cnn but the guy who was
giving his opinion
was the former director of national
intelligence for barack obama james
clapper this is a guy with a lot of
credibility or at least he's got
credible credentials he personally
doesn't have very much credibility at
all especially because he was totally
wrong oh yes this hunter-biden laptop
classic
russian tradecraft disinformation
oh yeah not even just all the videos and
pictures we see with hunter biden
obviously in it doing lots of creepy
stuff with drugs and sex and young girls
no no not just that
all the emails are fake probably it's
all fake it's all totally fake news
and uh so it's really dangerous and
we've got to suppress that information
except it was all true the new york
times just admitted the new york times
admitted in a headline hunter biden paid
tax bill but broad federal investigation
continues that's not the real story here
the real story is the laptop which the
new york times in this article admits
was
legit
so you've got now
the the way that this was being
presented yesterday is new york times
confirms that the hunter biden laptop
was real
the new york times didn't confirm it
we already knew the hunter biden laptop
was real that was already confirmed the
new york times did not do any
investigative journalism to show that
the the laptop was real
the new york times just admitted it
and it's good that's a that's a moral
victory for us isn't it
that that the new york times except they
admitted it after it didn't matter oh
whoopsy daisy we got it wrong and
censored all of you and suppressed your
information and rigged the election oops
guess we got it wrong okay moving on to
the next one it's propaganda that's how
propaganda works
okay it's not just our enemies overseas
that use this kind of propaganda and
censorship we do it too we do it to our
own citizens
now russia speaking of russia collusion
the bidens the clintons russia has just
sanctioned
joe biden
senior members of his staff and his
cabinet that we would expect right the
united states sanctions russia and top
russian leaders and now russia's
sanctioning the united states but there
were a couple people
that
russia sanctioned who are not in the
government right now russia sanctioned
hunter biden
and hillary clinton why that even
hillary was former secretary of state a
long time ago why would they sanction
her well
i don't know she's involved in politics
she at least was secretary of state why
hunter biden
the reason this this too is a sort of
form of propaganda the reason that
russia is sanctioning them and nobody is
talking about it
it's to call attention
to the fact that they both have had very
shady dealings in ukraine the clinton
foundation's top donors by nationality
were ukraine
i'm not saying the ukrainian government
i'm saying top uk ukraine is a corrupt
country just like russia is a corrupt
country just like a lot a lot of eastern
bloc places were corrupt
so top very wealthy ukrainians were the
top donors to the clinton global
initiative they had weird business
dealings there hunter biden had a
no-show job on the board of a ukrainian
energy company
why because of his expertise in
ukrainian
energy no he doesn't have expertise in
ukraine or energy it's because they were
trying to curry favor with joe biden
while his dad was point person on
ukraine issues for obama
and so russia's sanctioning them to call
attention to that fact very clever
propaganda speaking of hunter
there was a little tweet about sex work
that i really i do really want to get to
i've been meaning to get to it all week
it was this girl just this random girl
that kind of went viral i think libs of
tick tock posted it said i'm so effing
discouraged this month from subs i made
pretty much what most people would make
in two days at a normal job like what
even is the point of this anymore i'm
obviously not good enough not pretty
enough not skinny enough i literally am
so close to giving up
like this is my third year doing sex
work and i feel like i'm going insane
all i think about is how everyone else
is having so much success and i can't
even pay one bill with the amount i make
in a month f this
sad story for her but shows you the the
problem here just get a job just get a
real job
get a real job
well how dare you you're limiting me and
what i can you're right in a way i'm
limiting you from selling your body like
flesh and treating yourself like you're
an object i am limiting you in doing
that well but sex workers could make
more money no they can't they obviously
can't
very few of them can
and then most of them get screwed this
is how most
morally compromised deals work
you'll sometimes hear
people say who are in the sex industry
they'll say well i can just make so much
more money as a stripper than i can
working as a barista yeah maybe you can
right that's how temptation works
that's that's how these deals with the
devil work is yeah you think you can
gain a lot and
it's not worth it it's not worth selling
your soul and your dignity and your
integrity and your reputation and the
the most ironic part is usually
almost in the long run never but even in
the short run usually it doesn't really
work out one last thing i want to get to
before we get to the mailbag is this
issue of
of abortion drugs uh aoc and a bunch of
house stems are writing to the secretary
of health and human services to make it
easier to get abortion drugs this is a
really really bad idea okay
some conservatives i doubt very many but
some maybe some
more libertarian type conservatives
socially liberal fiscally conservative
they'll say this is great deregulation
just deregulate everything deregulate
birth control deregulate abortion drugs
no do not some regulation is good
regulation exists for a reason no one
has the right to an abortion just like
no one has a right to a baby okay this
is a real problem the the
commodification of sex like that sex
work and the commodification of babies
is a really bad problem really bad
problem in america okay you do not have
a right
to an abortion you do not have a right
to a baby a baby is a gift is not a
scourge it's not a plague of disease a
baby is a gift from god a baby has
certain rights that we have to respect a
baby has the right to his natural father
and mother okay this is why we protect
things like marriage this is why we
don't redefine marriage this is why we
don't redefine the family this is why we
don't
make technology the center of
human procreation this is why we have
long had bioethical moral strictures
against these sorts of things okay this
is a really bad problem not only
because of the children won't somebody
please think of the children not only
though that's a real concern but not
only because of that not only because of
what it does to
the
in individuals who are involved in it
but because of what it does to the way
we view humanity in the world okay we
are not just objects
to be treated like meat to be used for
each other's pleasure and to fulfill our
desires we are human beings made in the
image of god we have responsibilities to
one another okay and we have to respect
that we need to realize that when we're
talking to people we're dealing with
eternal beings okay and and that has to
be
respected otherwise we're all just meat
puppets trying to pursue our own own
desires until we turn into worm food and
take a dirt nap the third and final
episode
of
the fouchy unmasked docu-series i am
science
dropped this morning in it i take off
the final layer of fouchy's mask
revealing his unnatural rise to the top
it is uh a tremendous episode if i do
say so myself i really appreciate
everyone who has already watched this
series i've gotten
lots and lots of great feedback from all
of you this is only at dailywire.com so
head on over to dailywire.com check out
this sneak preview
he's the highest paid employee in our
federal government
and beginning in the spring of 2020 dr
fauci began to set national policy that
affected the way the 330 million
americans lived their lives for goodness
sakes i'm telling you where a mask keeps
social distancing there's nothing
political about that but who is anthony
fauci people who have conspiracy
theories those are people that don't
particularly care for me in this short
series
we will do what the establishment media
have refused to do
we will give you an unvarnished look at
the career of the most powerful
politician in america dr anthony
thatcher don't you think it's time that
you step down and let someone else who
has a more effective message
actually no
[Music]
the three-part series is streaming now
it is available exclusively at
dailywire.com if you're not a member
head on over to dailywire.com subscribe
to join today fouchy unmasked really
appreciate you for watching that also
we're releasing a special episode of
morning wire this sunday featuring our
own investigative reporter cassie dillon
she recently returned from the conflict
in ukraine she is joining john in
georgia to discuss the humanitarian
effort on the ground there the people
she met who are risking their lives to
make a difference make sure to check the
episode out sunday subscribe and start
listening now to morning wire on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts leave a five-star review if you
like what you hear also daily wires
first book 12 seconds in the dark by
sergeant mattingly is now available it's
a true story of what happened the night
of the brianna taylor shooting it's
available order your copy today because
it is going to sell out we will be right
back with the mailbag
welcome back to my favorite time of the
week when i get to hear from you in the
mailbag first question up is from kyle
hello dw wiseman knowles
i've really enjoyed all the movies and
series coming out of the daily wire i
especially enjoyed the fouchy unmasked
series thank you very much my question
is why did you decide to do it which
episode was your favorite and any
behind-the-scenes stories that you can
tell hashtag firefoxy uh we decided to
do it because dr fauci
first of all gas led us all for two
years and
and just changed story left and right
and we were still supposed to call him
not only an expert but the science he
was actually the representative of
science when in fact he was nothing more
than a craven politician but
two
because he was the most powerful
politician in america and he was so
powerful that he actually hid a lot of
his power but he's the most powerful
he's the highest paid employee of the
federal government he's a guy who's been
around for 40 years he's served under
what seven presidential administrations
and joe biden the current president said
that he would never fire him under no
circumstances would he fire him i
thought just from a political standpoint
he said how the hell does someone get
this much political power
it's
shocking to me
so we did the series it's a three-part
series a little little extra part at the
end too my favorite episode is actually
episode two because it's the
it's the episode with i i felt stuff
that really had not been covered
anywhere i mean i think every episode
has stuff that has not been covered
anywhere but
episode two you just trace this guy's
rise from the 80s to the present he
didn't he didn't become the most
powerful guy in america overnight okay
and i think it's important to learn how
he did it so that we can one stop him
come november and two prevent
others like him from rising up next
question from camille nolstradamus
since you continue to prove you know
best i need some advice i went out with
a guy who was nice enough but felt no
type of romantic feelings at all he
texted me after saying he'd like to hang
out again but i just don't see my
feelings changing
how should i let him down easy
there is no great way to deliver
rejection and ghosting him just feels
cruel so what's the best way to do it
sincerely
love don't come easy i would i would be
pretty direct with him
don't string them along whatever you do
you're going to think that's easier and
it's not so i you could say honestly
that you're uh
right now you're actually
sort of involved with uh someone else
and uh you know that's sort of
maybe going somewhere no it's not it
wouldn't be a lie first of all maybe you
are i don't know how many people you're
dating but two
you're we're all involved with other
people and our relationships with those
people are going somewhere so it
wouldn't be a lie but i would make it
very clear
you don't have to say hey i think you're
ugly but if you if you come out and just
say hey
i am romantically interested in someone
else
it's not you
right it's it's a way to kind of okay
well maybe she was with this guy before
me or maybe whatever and uh but it's a
clear line okay
i'm not
i'm not going anywhere here he might
think just because there's a goalie
doesn't mean he can't score but that's
his problem at least you i think
were as direct as you could be from eli
hey michael
big fan of the show love both of your
books even the one with words thank you
very much i want to ask your opinion on
tattoos and if it's immoral in the
catholic faith to get one personally
i've had issues with depression and have
some scars i want to cover up but i am
hesitant any advice would be greatly
appreciated thanks another suare the
italian conservative
uh you know i'm not uh the biggest
tattoo guy myself
uh you know i was not a sailor i have
not been a boxer
i've never been a convict so i you know
i don't think i can totally pull it off
you know never was in the marines
but there's nothing immoral about
tattoos as far as i can tell i don't
think there's any uh
there is one
uh
sort of commandment against it in the
ceremonial law of the ancient israelites
but i don't think this in any way
extends to the moral law that certainly
is not traditionally the teaching of the
church so i think you're you're okay to
get a tattoo my only hesitation in your
case
is you say you're getting a tattoo to
cover up
this
tough thing in your past
i don't know that
covering it up
isn't necessarily the way out
you maybe you try to get some kind of
cosmetic surgery to lessen whatever
scores you've got
but and look maybe the tattoo is the way
to go i'm not sure perhaps it is you've
moved past whatever emotional problems
you had psychological problems and and
now you just really want to put it
behind you
but
don't
don't just try to paper over a problem
if that problem is still a real problem
don't focus on the tattoo don't focus on
the cover-up focus on the problem and
making sure that that is all the way
gone but if you're afraid that uh if you
get a tattoo you won't go to heaven i do
not think that is the case from sarah
hey michael
i have sort of an out of left field
question but i figured you're the master
of giving advice on strange situations
what does that say about me my friend is
gay and he invited me to a gay bar
birthday party i love my friend and
enjoy hanging out with him but i'm
christian and feel it would not be
appropriate to attend a gay wedding but
a gay bar party feels like a gray area
what do you think
the issue you're talking about here is
the issue of scandal right
presumably you're not going to be
participating in some gay orgy at this
party but
you're worried about the idea that
you're a christian and you would feel
dishonest and perhaps that you were
leading other people astray you would be
giving into the sin of scandal if you
showed up to this
it's a gray area because i don't even
know exactly what you mean by
gay bar
here's about i'll give you an example i
used to live in l.a there's a an
infamous bar in west hollywood called
the abbey
this is probably the most well-known gay
bar in all of l.a and la's a pretty gay
town
the abbey is an extraordinarily
sacrilegious
gay bar because it's built to look like
an abbey it's built to look like a like
a church you know with all this
christian symbolism but inverted i mean
quite literally perverted to serve not a
higher religious purpose but to serve
this sexual political agenda
so if if the birthday party were being
held at the abbey i would say
no don't go you know that you forget the
sex issue is almost beside the point
here it's because it would be so
sacrilegious and so scandalous to go
if the party were at
just a bar that has a reputation right
you walk in it's a bar like any other
bar it's got drinks behind the bar it's
got people chatting and dancing around
and it just happens to be known in town
as a gay bar well that i think is very
different all sorts of bad things happen
in all sorts of bars so if you're going
to go to a bar anyway i'm not sure that
that is a total impediment to going to
your friend's birthday
now here's where the real gray area
comes in
if it's a bar
that
is not you know making a mockery of
christianity
with you know crucifixes and things on
the walls
if it's a
bar that is not just a regular bar with
a reputation but let's say it's a bar
that makes the rainbow flag part of its
theme right that makes gay
lgbt political advocacy part of its
theme then that's a much grayer area
i
actually like my uh
[Music]
more right-wing gay friends really don't
like the rainbow flag i think rainbow
flag is a horrible political symbol and
i i don't want to be associated with it
at all
and there are people with same sex
attractions even who act out on those
same-sex attractions who would agree
with that statement and say oh i hate
the rainbow the rainbow stuff is insane
don't let me in with those crazy people
well so if the bars got that flag i'm
probably not going to go
um i would probably lean on that side
but i do acknowledge it's a gray area
that would be my analysis of the
situation you're going to have to tailor
your response to wherever you feel the
the bar itself and the crowd itself
would fall on that spectrum from ellie
hi michael i'm 24 years old i live in
maryland
beside the four years i spent at texas a
m i've always lived within a 20-mile
radius of my entire extended family i'm
dating slash in love with a guy that
works for the government and relocates
every five or so years i see a future
with him and an amazing life for myself
and my future children but i'm
struggling with the idea of having my
kids grow up away from the rest of their
family we're extremely close family that
gathers all the time my question for you
is how important do you think it is for
family to be physically present in your
kid's life i am doing my kids a
disservice if they grow up outside of
the states away am i rather uh
doing my kids a disservice if they grow
up outside of the states away from
grandparents family being with him means
my kid's only seeing family a few times
a year thank you and congrats on the
upcoming tiny human hashtag came for ben
stayed for knowles
you asked me and so i'm going to give
you
what i did
i live very far away from my extended
family and from my
father and from my
cousins and from my
stepbrother and from my grandparents and
from i i live in nashville
no one in my family lives in tennessee
other than my immediate family my wife
and my kids
before that i lived in l.a i moved all
the way from new york i lived in l.a i
moved as far away from new york as you
can within the continental united states
i wasn't near my family
my grandparents have the greatest
marriage and family i've ever seen in my
life
my grandpa was a navy captain they moved
every few years all over the place all
throughout the united states throughout
the world in belgium all over
and that meant they couldn't see
extended family means that i cannot see
extended family my kids can't see
extended family
i'm not saying that's a good thing
but that was my grandpa's career and i'm
very focused on my career and that's
important and we're prioritizing that
and we pay a price for that
i wish we could see family more
frequently
one it would save on child care you got
to pay for all these babysitters you
could just call up you know auntie so
and so and then you get free child care
but also i want to see my family i want
to spend time with them and we can't
that's the price that i'm paying for my
career
maybe that's the price you're willing to
pay
i think it's really good and
conservative and healthy to live near
your extended family i think that's a
really special thing
the price for that might be that you
don't get to have that career you want
or in your case you might not get to
have the husband you want
i wish i could give you a simple answer
here you know what you know what i chose
because of
i'm professionally ambitious all right
that was a that's been a focus of mine
since i was very little not everyone
looks at their job the same way
the advice i have for you is not this is
better than this my advice is these are
the costs and there are there are
necessarily going to be costs and there
is no cost-free answer
so you've got to ask yourself
what price are you willing to pay
for this guy
and for his career
or what price are you willing to pay
to be near your extended family
i promise you one thing though you're
not going to be getting out of this
without paying some price last question
from ava hello nostradamus i had a
conversation with my neighbor the other
day about religion he was born and
raised catholic he says he believes in
god and loves god that he also believes
that the world would be better off
without religion
doesn't sound like he loves god very
much
he says that religion can be divisive
and religious divisiveness is what
started the crusades
okay i agree with him that certain
religions can be exclusionary as they
should be in order to maintain
traditions et cetera but i never thought
that the core reason for war and unrest
starting would be because of religious
divide is my neighbor onto something
could the world be more peaceful without
religion thank you for your advice love
the show uh i think your friend is right
in that
the wars of the world begin because of
religion
i think all politics comes down to
religion and i don't think it's possible
to get rid of religion because we are
rational beings and we think about
things and we don't just think about
what food we want to eat and we don't
just think about tax rates we think
about why we're eating this we think
about why we lower the tax rates we
think about how we want to live we think
about what is good and what is bad and
what is right what is wrong what is true
and what is false how we know what truth
is how we know what goodness is those
are all religious questions you cannot
escape it
man is fundamentally a religious being
he mentioned the crusades the crusades
actually were a very good war it's one
of the great tragedies in history that
the christian west did not win the
crusades it was a defensive war against
muslims who were invading everywhere
they could invade that's a topic for
another day
religion is not some awful thing to be
discarded people very often say i'm
spiritual but not religious i'm
spiritual which really means i'm
interested in myself i'm not that
interested in god
go back to your deuteronomy
go back to exodus
god
explains how he wants to be worshipped
with the the tabernacle the ark the
dress for the priests
beyond all that
the moral law how he wants
you to relate to him okay religion helps
us
religion far from making uh our
spiritual life superstitious or
unnecessarily complicated religion
applies reason religion applies rigor
religion allows us to think much more
clearly
about who god is who we are how we
relate to him it it actually
reigns in the crazy superstitious
eccentricities of spirituality and and
allows it to be grounded in
in
something real something tangible it
allows it to be grounded in the truth so
no you're not going to get rid of
religion you just need to work through
religious questions and come to
religious truth i'm michael knowles it's
the michelle show see you monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin